coronavirus isn't dangerous for me so
I'm not worried and besides the chance
that I'll actually get it is basically
zero these are two of the most common
reasons I hear why someone is not
worried about curve at 19 and why
they're not doing much about it I want
to explain in this video why they make
no sense and why staying at home is an
effective thing that you can do to stop
the spread of this virus and why you
should okay so quick interruption I
finished filming this just before I
heard the news that the USA government
now recommends that no more than 10
people meet at the same place which i
think is excellent news and I'm super
relieved to hear it so I really hope
other countries follow suit and the rest
this video is going to explain why I
think you should follow this advice
whether you're in America or not it is
true that if you're young and healthy
that your own chance of death from this
disease are very low but let's say that
you were to get sick
at the current rate you're likely to
spread it to two to three other people
other people that you're in contact with
all healthy to perhaps they are but
remember each of them will spread it to
two to three more people and they each
spread it to two to three themselves and
so on there are going to be vulnerable
people fairly close to you that the
virus reaches directly because you got
sick an elderly person someone with
diabetes someone with chronic
respiratory problems for me this would
be my grandma my dad and my cousin and
looking at these death probabilities
makes it real for me and remember each
of the people you might spread the virus
to has their own people to be worrying
about as well if you reduce the number
of people you infect even though you
might not see it this has a huge
positive ripple effect you are directly
responsible for the lives of people some
you know many who you don't but maybe
you think that you're not likely to get
this disease after all in the u.s. right
now there's only a few thousand cases
compared
to a population of a few hundred million
and so yeah right now your probability
is very low but it's changing fast I
mean even a week ago this whole thing
felt a lot less serious right and
honestly I was very surprised by this
too until I stopped and did this little
calculation so you've probably heard the
number of cases being reported daily in
the news but that's not what's important
what's important is the answer to this
question how many days would it take for
the number of cases in your country to
go up by a factor of ten so to get ten
times bigger for example there are
roughly 5,000 cases in the US right now
but how much longer until you have
50,000 cases a couple of months maybe a
few weeks that's not it if things keep
going in the same trend as they have
been in the USA right now then the
number of cases goes up by a factor of
ten in just one week so if nothing were
to change next week is 50,000 more than
the number in Italy right now in two
weeks it would be 500,000 and in just
three weeks it would be five million
it's a similar rate of growth in all the
other countries that haven't yet taken
drastic measures like lock downs if you
remember no other statistic from this
video just remember this if we don't
take drastic actions then this problem
gets ten times worse in one week every
week if people are still allowed to go
outside freely for example like in these
countries right now and this is roughly
the number of cases there are at the
moment next week you will have ten times
that and again the week after and again
but it doesn't need to be like this
our main focus should be on increasing
this time from a week to a lot longer so
that the spread is slower for example
Italy was until it's locked down at a
similar rate 10 times worse in one week
but has now slowed that time to about
seven
teen days we have to accept that this
disease is probably still going to
spread very widely but we need to make
that spread go in as slow motion as we
can manage that might sound like a
stupid idea
I mean why drag out the inevitable well
hopefully you've seen this brilliant
infographic from dr. Susie Wiles
that explains it if the number of cases
keeps raising this fast we will have a
lot of cases all at once and suddenly
there will be way more sick people than
hospitals can treat at once for example
in the USA there's only about 350,000
beds for coronavirus patients which is
nowhere near enough if this virus is
going to keep spreading at the rate it
is now hospitals will be swamped once
that happens doctors will start having
to make decisions about who will live
because not everyone can be careful on
the other hand if we can seriously slow
the spread of this disease then there
may be enough healthcare to go around
this isn't just hypothetical either you
might have heard that the death rate of
Kovac 19 is less than 1% but that's in
places where everyone can still get
treatment in places that have been
overwhelmed the death rate is more like
three to five percent but it could
become even higher if a health care
system is truly overworked this is why
we need to slow it down because we don't
want to be in the position where one in
every 20 people who get this disease
will die not because they have to but
because we didn't have the resources to
save them so how can we slow the spread
here's a useful simulation from The
Washington Post that explains it get the
blue dots represent healthy people but
the brown dots represent people with the
virus when an infected person comes into
contact with someone else they will
spread the virus to them when a person
with the virus recovers they become
purple to show that they can no longer
in fact or be infected let's see what
happens when everyone is allowed to
mingle freely like they still are in a
lot of places
as you can see very very quickly there
is a huge number of people sick at the
same time this is when hospitals will be
jammed and doctors are working until
they collapse or get ill so how can we
slow this down well what did we ask
everyone to stay home if they can limit
contact with others as much as possible
let's simulate this by getting most of
these dots to stop moving to represent
people staying at home there will still
be some people who can't for example
because they just can't work from home
these people are still moving and able
to spread the disease but see how slow
that spread is now there's way fewer
people who are sick at the same time
there are two main reasons that staying
at home like this works the first is
that your probability of getting sick is
now so much lower because you're much
less likely to meet someone who's
infected but also you're much less
likely to spread the disease even if you
were to get sick because you're not
meeting as many people this is called
social distancing and it's saves lives
companies can save lives by asking
employees to work from home and possible
universities and schools can save lives
by having classes remotely or simply
shutting down religious leaders can save
lives by asking their congregation to
pray from home
rather than gathering event organizers
can save lives by cancelling matches and
festivals and governments can save lives
by making all of this mandatory and you
can save lives too by avoiding
non-essential gatherings even things
like going to dinner with friends
especially if you have the main symptoms
of this disease which are a fever and a
drive cough you can save lives by
isolating yourself but just to be clear
you should be staying home even if
you're not sick that's because over 20%
of the infections come from people
without any symptoms yet from people who
think that they're fine and so they
continue to go about their lives meeting
others and inadvertently making them
sick as well these are all the Rays
that social distancing makes sense but I
know it's tough and you're probably
thinking that you're going to go crazy
but there are a few things that you can
do to make it a little bit easier
the first is call your family and your
friends and your colleagues for no
reason at all just to chat for example
the place where I'm about to start a job
is now completely working from home but
every lunchtime they video call each
other so that they can share a meal
together virtually it's super important
to make sure that you're talking to
people at least once a day so call your
friends secondly look after your
physical health as well you only need to
be avoiding people not sunlight so in
most places you can still go outside for
a walk lastly try keep yourself
productively occupied in your newfound
spare time there's only so many movies
that you can watch before you feel
frustrated that you're not doing
anything so maybe take this as your
chance to learn that thing that you've
been wanting to learn or to read more or
to finish one of your projects the point
is this though staying inside saves
lives so thank you for doing this by
other people but remember to look after
yourself as well just make sure you
don't go crazy good luck